où
[Musique]
sorj chalandon vous êtes écrivain
journaliste vous avez longtemps exercé
en tant que reporter de guerre pour le
journal libération ce qui vous a valu
entre autres le prix albert londres je
ne sais pas si vous êtes revenu de tout
mais en tout cas vous êtes revenu de
loin et notamment d'une enfance dont on
ne guérit jamais vraiment votre père
vous a inspiré une oeuvre hantée par les
doubles et les traîtres après dix romans
etes-vous toujours une bombe selon vos
propres termes ou l'écriture at elle
fini par épuiser la violence qu'il a
semés en vous
moi j'ai en fait j'ai pas envie de
tourner les pages je déteste ce mot il
faut tourner la page si on tourne la
page on a tout oublié moi ce que
j'aimerais ce que j'essaye de faire
c'est de vivre avec les pages jeux ce
que ce que j'ai vécu c'est mon socle la
douleur c'est mon socle les blessures
c'est mon sox ses coûts c'est mon sauf
les humiliations cbre socle aussi ai-je
fait attention que que les plaies soit
pas tout à fait refermée quand les gens
de 10,5 à vous écrire un livre après
vous vous sentez mieux la pensée non
mais vous et moi maintenant on partage
quelque chose et ce qui est bouleversant
pour moi c'est que je n'écris pas pour
guérir mais j'écris pour pour pour
échanger avec d'autres on glissera c'est
marrant parce que j'aurais pu écrire ce
livre là y voit ça c'est une merveille
votre père était un serial cogneur les
serial menteur tantôt pasteur est
ceinture noire de judo vente aux
parachutistes et espion il a été ami
léon zitrone amendée de piaf résistons
proche de jean moulin agent secret de la
cia je crois que ces derniers
conseillers occultes du général de
gaulle jusqu'à la guerre d'algérie où
ils se sont engueulés je crois qu'il ya
les derniers à avoir quitté dien bien
phu ap ira à oui c'est papa c'est votre
père comment arrive-t-on à se construire
au milieu d'une telle galerie de
personnages dans l'ombre d'un tel
faussaires qui n'avait pas son pareil
pour mêler le fo'o vraisemblable mais
d'abord je ne sais pas moi j'ai dix ans
j'ai engrangé 12 ans simon peut pas dit
qu'il agent secret mon peuple est agent
secret quand avez vous compris que votre
père mentait leurs petites applis dont
ce qui m'a étonné d'abord sais c'est que
chaque jour chaque jour ou presque
chaque matin il arrivait avec un métier
différent et quand vous avez dit ccc
tester posté par il n'était pas si tu te
relèves s'était pas totalement je me
souviens que quand le franc lourd
nouveaux francs a été mis en place nous
étions s'essaie pour moi c'est une image
qui est magique mais qui explique bien
ça nous sommes à table donc il pas la
télé il mêlait radio et d'un coup mon
père en tant qu antoine pinay et vient
de décréter le nouveau front au pays il
l'a fait ça fait 20 ans que je que je
n'embête que je remette avec ça donc je
retourne en classe et tous les copains
dit c'est quoi cette heure de nouveaux
francs jeudi simon peut pas de mon papa
qui l'inventé je ne sais pas qu'il
mangeait pas beaucoup ri de moi mais
petit à petit comme il ya une telle
une texture cession de drôle de métier
quand vous dites qu'il voit là il était
pasteur ce pasteur presbytérien puisque
j'étais un gaucher contrarié on
m'interdisait d'écrire de la main gauche
on m'a attaché la main pour passer la
main du diable dont il faut pas écrire
de la main gauche et dont ils ont réussi
j'écris la main droite mais après ces
deux buts voilà donc la plupart des
colchiques ont travaillé de mon âge sont
bègue et et donc il était devenu pasteur
presbytérien pour enlever le diable qui
était en moi c'est le diable qui me
faisait gaucher et quand je me suis mis
à bégayer il m'a dit que habib sais pas
ce que tu veux être moqué de nouveaux
publics personne ne franchit d'autres la
porte personne ne rapporte jamais c'est
à dire qu'en fait comme c'était un
menteur chaque fois qu'il était démasqué
occulter les personnes qui l'avait
démasqué ce à commencer par la famille
puis par les amis puis par les collègues
de de ma mère est petit à petit en fait
c'était
en fait c'étaient ces tests est une
secte petite secte quand il était le
gourou il était le gourou et est
maintenant c'est terrible ce que
maintenant avec le recul je pense que
c'est un homme qui aurait pu avoir droit
de vie et de mort sur nous comme ben
comme roman où ces grandes affaires
criminelles après mais je pense qu'il
aurait pu il aurait pu nous tuer mais
pas pour nous faire du mal pour en finir
avec nous tous et avec lui aussi mais je
n'ai pas compris tout de suite que tout
ça était faux j'ai compris dans le
regard des autres et mon frère parce
qu'il est mon frère il est donc il il
est papa petit à 19 points de moins que
moi après que mon père soit mort je lui
ai dit mais comment ça se fait parce
qu'il n'a jamais cru mans perd jamais
aucune de ces histoires aucune plus
petit fait pourquoi moi j'y croyais et
m'a dit parce que tu les mets
c'est là la réponse la plus violente qui
m'était faire justement quel impact a eu
les mensonges de cet homme que vous
aimiez j'imagine par exemple que vous
n'êtes pas devenu correspondant de
guerre par hasard votre souci de la
vérité la traque et la restituer oui il
me semble ça a été un antidote une façon
de réparer ces manquements à la vérité
non pour pour moi c'était s'était
d'abord comprendre comprendre qui est
qui et entendre et écouter ce qu'ils qui
ne faisait jamais donc que tout d'un
coup je me suis je me suis d'abord je me
suis ouvert
le sua ouvert c'est à dire que ce métier
là pour moi c'était un moyen d'aller
quelque part d'aller voir les êtres de
les entendre et d'apprendre d'eux est
donc le journalisme m'a semblé allant
même assemblée le meilleur moyen d'être
d'être dans un lieu et de faire la part
entre le mensonge et la vérité est sympa
et évitant tout de suite j'imagine que
reporter de guerre c'était aussi une
façon de confronter votre propre
violence à l'atrocité peut-être de
trouver finalement votre vérité au coeur
du désastre et de répondre à cette
question comment renaître la vie quand
on revient de si loin moi j'ai eu
un aveu un peu quand même
un peu leur désaveu quand on me dit tu
voulais être reporter de guerre pourquoi
parce que c'est vrai parce que je
voulais être là où les choses se
passaient je voulais comprendre ça c'est
absolument exact l'autre chose c'est que
j'étais bien
en guerre c'est bien pas parce qu'il y
avait des morts mais parce que j'étais
dans un lieu où le mensonge peut pas
exister j'étais bien parce que en france
en dire un copain tiens on se voit
demain au café machin puis le mec il est
pas là on dire aux pas grave regarde
fais pas ça en guerre tu es rendez vous
demain tu viens demain parce que c'est
une question d'orgueil on se dit on se
dit au revoir on sait pas si on se
reverra le lendemain matin donc ce
moment de la guerre elle est là je ne
parle pas du sang je parle pas des
crimes papa je parle de cette ce moment
où on est dans un moment de l'humanité
qui est telle que c'est c'était que le
mensonge peut vous coûter la vie et le
mensonge peut nous coûter la vie et ses
effets tu sais je prends je me
paraphrase mais il ya une joie féroce
qui nous porte chaque jour chaque matin
chaque minute pense donc j'avais deux
choses journalistes lorsque la guerre en
turquie je suis moi qu'est ce que j'ai
dans mon ventre et ça c'est quelque
chose que que la peine offre pas la
peine a pas fan nous la met la peine
nous regarde voilà en bois se pique ou
en terrasse on se marre la guerre à la
fin de nous la gamme nous bouffe et moi
toujours me demander mais avant d'y
aller je ne savais pas qu est ce que
j'ai dans mon ventre moi je suis pas
super g un sur heroes sur un
lâche et je sais pas j'ai un bourreau
qu'est ce que je suis et quand j'étais
vous êtes gagnez vous même je me suis
cognée alors je me suis cogné à mon père
parce que c'est des trucs très très bête
mais mon père c'était l'un des meilleurs
amis du petit roi hussein de jordanie
qu'on peut pas cru bon et b quand je me
retrouve dans le 2e set de journée où
par tradition quand on fait une
interview ensuite tous les journées ils
sont là on lui serre la main pour brut
pour la photo je pense tout de suite moi
papa je le fais bon c'est rien c'est
tout bête mais tout d'un coup j'avais
l'impression d'être sur ses traces avec
la vérité et surtout
je savais sa séduction pour pour revenir
en paix et pour être père il fallait que
ce puisse être père et pour être père il
fallait que j'aie puise véritable musée
puisse véritablement clamer en outre la
violence qu'il avait mise en boîte
qu'est-ce qui épuise la violence c'est
la guerre c'est à dire qu au delà soit
on y va soit en tuer canton durner c'est
quelque chose qui est moi je me souviens
d'un vieux palestinien ccc jeudi noir
militants mais lis pas ce que c'était
bouleversant
j'étais à tripoli dans le nord du liban
sous scellés bombardements syriens
s'étaient qu'arafat ayant un vieux pc un
qui me prend comme ça mais c'était
bouleversant c'est un vieux monsieur il
me prend comme ça il me regarde dans les
yeux dit toi tu n'as pas tuer
les yeux dans le regard et moi je
voulais apprendre ce qu'était que le
regard de celui qui a pas tués et regard
de celui qui a tué ses dents 4e facile
en quatrième mur et
et une fois que j'ai épuisé la violence
de mon père il faut épuiser les
mensonges de mon père je me suis dis pas
je crois que je vais pouvoir être père
alors justement ce jour-là vous avaient
déserté les zones de conflits décidé
d'arrêter découvrir est-ce que néanmoins
vous avez gardé de cette pas d'un
syndrome post traumatique
oui oui j'ai un syndrome post
traumatique mais je savais pas que le
mot existe et je l'aï appris après en
regardant les les séries américaines si
les séries israéliennes qui sont
supprimés non je ne je ne mettais pas de
mot là dessus mais en fait
quand j'ai eu mes enfants j'ai trois
filles
j'ai un jour un problème avec ma fille
qui était petit qui fait tomber une
boule de glace dans un square qui se met
à pleurer et moi je conseille au relais
c'est à dire que j'ai eus an mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut pleurer pour
une boule de glace et je commence à dire
un enfant qui était minuscule alors que
des enfants sont en train de mourir pour
de l'eau au liban pourquoi les gens
étaient autour c'est très particulier
j'étais une sorte de monstre et dans ses
yeux dans les yeux de mon enfant qui me
regardait rêver l'incompréhension j'ai
fait un enfant sous les bombes je
connaissais ce regard et moi j'étais
rentré de de guerre mais comme comme
tant d'autres si si vous parlez lorsque
vous parlez avec le reporter de 2,2 de
guerre c'est la même chose vous revenez
avec vous l'avait rapporté avec vous et
c'est jean paul mari qui a fait un très
un très beau film qui s'appelait sans
blessures apparentes a blessé sur le
syndrome post traumatique et qui a
interrogé
journaliste grand journaliste qui a
acquis interroger des soldats et c'est
qui qui m'interroge et moi j'accepte
parce que c'est un ami et je lui parle
de sabra et chatila donc les camps
palestiniens massacrés par les
phalangistes et là je leur sers que tout
d'un coup ressort quelque chose que je
n'attendais pas ceux des années après et
je deviens tout rouge tout le truc de la
télé qui est épouvantable une sorte de
grosse citrouille pleurante on coupe une
bille sorges écrit je t'en supplie écrit
là-dessus en fait tout était là il a
fallu qu'il fallait que je l'écrive
tardivement il a fallu qu en fait il a
fait que je me lave dans le quatrième
mur dont vous venez de parler un homme
bien monté l'antigone d'anouilh sur un
champ de bataille au liban le quatrième
mur pour ceux qui ne le savent pas et
désigne cet espace virtuel qui sépare la
scène du public c'est ce mur invisible
sens et isoler la scène des fureurs
extérieur vous sort juste de l'amour
extérieur ou de l'amour extérieur ou son
châle en dos rien n'est jamais venu se
dresser entre la réalité et la fiction
est l'infection de votre père n'ont
aucune muraille près des couples était
jeune et je n'ai pas alors je me suis
protégé ensuite en écrivant en prenant
un masque de carnaval en prenant un
métier qui n'est pas le mien je suis
luthier je suis je suis restaurateur de
tableaux de 19e j'ai un autre prénom
mais je ne suis pas protéger des coups
de mon père maintenant ça y est mais
c'était d'ailleurs cessé extrêmement
étrange parce que j'ai
je vais avoir 70 ans et j'ai
l'impression sauf pour mon ami mais j'ai
l'impression que j'essaie de vendre à
l'enfant qui a écrit c'est toujours
l'enfant qui a écrit sur son père et
pour la première fois j'ai l'impression
que c'est le le père de mes filles qui
vient d'écrire cg je sais comme si il la
fallait tout ça pour que je devienne
père dans ma tête et que je sois plus
simplement le fils de et que ce soit le
père de et que voilà alors on va refaire
cet itinéraire ensemble du fils de opère
deux dans votre tout premier roman sort
challandes où le petit bonzi vous
brossier le portrait d'un jeune bugs et
les tourments de l'enfance cette petite
jungle où les plus fragiles doivent
apprendre à se défendre comme votre
héros vous avez dit vous étiez lebègue
vrac me suis toujours quand je suis
énervé
mais vous raconter 4 bègue ça vous a
appris par la force des choses à être
plus précis du ritz a été une chance au
fond alors j'aurais préféré ne pas
sincèrement parce que le bégaiement est
quand même le seul handicap qui fait
rire et masques baisse que ce que le
bégaiement m'a appris c'est le sait la
valeur du mot en sachant quatre banques
ce n'est pas manquer nos savoirs trop de
mots trop de mots très important de mots
et mais so foot vraiment une idée reçue
bien sûr tous vos mots sont la sophro
pas sortir quand le mot ne venait pas il
fallait que j'en ai d'autres et donc en
fait moi j'ai toujours des métaphores
militaires un petit peu donc je suis un
officier on va prendre d'assaut la
colline il faut des mots il faut des
mots alors la pomme et les rouges la
pomme et les hausses après y avait la
peau mais va être garance elle va être
pour prévenir rhône à aller au plus près
je peux arriver c'est pour ça qu'on
prenait un peu pour un album quand
j'étais petite à dire que ben elle était
jaune vient parce que je ça passe mieux
c'est monstrueux lorsque vous êtes
enfant en classe puis il faudra que la
papa puis sa part le pilote vous pouvez
pas vous pouvez pas quand vous êtes
balle optique et dans un coin comme ceux
rendus où il est traité libre reçues
elles n'ont pas du tout les bébés la
peur de vous il a peur de vous et vous
avez longtemps peur de la nuit sorj
chalandon au petit vous ne dormez pas
vous étiez vaillante sentinelles à
l'affût car vos nuits d'enfance était
l'ennemi du loup garous les nuits du
minotaure les nuits de barbe bleue barbe
bleue ce n'est pas juste pour vous un
conte de charles perrault n'est ce pas
non barbe bleue c'est
barbe-bleue c'est celui qui va rentrer
dans la chambre qui va vous mangez et
qui faisait irruption tel votre père
chaque nuit bien sûr user sans crier
gare sans s'en créer gamme et je les
attendais c'est à dire que je savais
qu'ils allaient venir mettant avec cross
qui pensent maintenant tous ces gros
grotesque avec un pantalon de pyjama un
marcel et des mules et quand il rentre
je suis sentie soldats ans quand il me
fait faire il fait faire des pompes
m'engueuler ces termes est pour moi
l'une des pires choses dont je me
souviens est ce assez il faut je sais
pas il faut qu'un fils mère aucun père
s'imagine qu'un enfant si magique
c'était le cachot la punition le cachot
c'était une grande armoire au pied du
lit de mes parents il m'avait quand
j'avais 23 ans mata les bombes sur une
mauvaise note j'étais enfermé à
l'intérieur à clé ne dormait dans le lit
moi j'étais quoi il fallait que je reste
à genoux avec les mains sur la tête dans
l'armoire la nuit la nuit entière et de
temps en temps il aa il ouvrait la porte
pour assiter toujours à genoux et
toujours les mains sur la tête
comment on se rend sorte de ce supplice
la des coûts des hurlements du sang des
hurlements en allemand dans ce sauf moi
je me suis je me suis sauvé les sauver
mais le plus dur c'est que
il a fallu que j'apprenne avec mes films
coco comment comment est ce qu'on
raconte une histoire le soir assis à
côté du lit comme on leur dit méfie
encore maintenant mais lorsque j'étais
petit je leur disais pas je t'aime et je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime trois fois
coco comment comment on fait après j'ai
regarder les autres faire encore
maintenant c'est les choses très
bizarres parce qu'il m'a il m'a laissé
des choses du d'une violence inouïe et
que que je cache un truc idiot nous
sommes dans une fête de fin d'année les
enfants surtout sur scène c'est le
pestacle de fin d'année à l'école et les
parents qui fument qui se marrer tous
et moi je regarde comment on fait pour
pour montrer qu'on est heureux
marché comme les autres et tout ça mais
au fond de moi une sorte de gouffre je
n'y arrive pas et je me dis c'est
connaissent ce plus qui m'a fait parce
que ça et maintenant encore je
regarde les autres bafiba fixement les
regards à la dérobée
pour pour savoir comment on montre à son
enfant concon riz par exemple mais ce
qui est étrange c'est que malgré les
dents cassées des coûts les bleus vous
qualifier ce père de magicien il vous a
fait également rêver sapin ci avait pas
eu les coups sincèrement sur vais pas eu
les couche-tard s'est empressé
agitateurs c'est à dire que cox quand
même chaque jour arriver avec un métier
nouveau c'est formidable et il m'a
raconté sa guerre tout était faux
évidemment pas et qu'en mai lorsqu'il
attaque seul un cinéma allemand à la
grenade etc et moi je suis là donc oui
il est il marche dans la chambre dans
une demi-obscurité il imitera tard il
fait des bruits des des mitrailleuses
mais c'est papa ces immenses et c'est
la seule chose qui m'inquiète un petit
peu c'est que
c'est que des fois ils me regardent avec
beaucoup d'attention comme s'ils
attendaient quelque chose de moi en fait
il sait comme s'ils avaient voulu
3 qu'il voulait mais blue et puma
aveugle et il nous a tous aveugles et
j'ai un souvenir ça c'est quelque chose
qui est qu'il ya incroyable et là je
commençais déjà à voir les défenses en
fait je me souviens une fois il hurlait
il voulait voir si je pleurais c'était
dans l'obscurité de la voiture et moi je
savais qu'il allait faire ça j'ai
mouillé mon pouce me suis mis des larmes
comme ça il a touché il a dit c'est bien
tu pleures alors que je ne pleurais pas
à 16 ans vous fugué
vous dorment à la belle étoile sous les
ponts souvent les halls d'immeuble les
halls d'immeuble de quoi ils vivent ou à
l'époque à l'époque il ya encore des
petites bouteilles de lait le matin donc
vraiment sa part nié avoir excusé il y
avait le pain pas jeter le soir dans les
restaurants il y avait déjà un souvenir
fait maintenant que ça ça paraît insensé
mais par exemple on dormait pas la
manche on faisait les poubelles je
voulais pas faire l'amour je voulais pas
jouer je trouve ça absolument indigne je
ne pouvais pas tendre la main c'est pas
possible je suis désolé je voyais ça
comme ça mais j'aurais préféré voler que
tempérament en tout cas l'époque est tel
que on se rend pas compte mais par
exemple le vert-galant donc ccc à paris
c'est sous le pont neuf
je dormais des fois au vert galant l'été
mais on pouvait être deux à trois cents
gamins qui dormiront là il y avait 300
mômes dans les sacs de couchage qui
dormait là c'est à dire que alors alors
nous appeler les hippies les beatniks
etc mais j'avais pas le besoin d'être
sdf j'ai l'impression d'être sorti j'ai
sorti après peu importe puis après bomba
a brillé une libération avant libération
si vous rencontrez la cause du peuple
l'extrême gauche j'ai le sentiment que
plus qu'une famille de pensée ça a été
ça vous a tenu lieu de vraie famille
s'est battue et sert que voilà je gg 16
ans chez un petit lyonnais je prends le
train sans payer et j'arrive à la gare
de lyon et suis tout petit j'ai et
j'entends des gens qui vendent un
journal je connais pas la cause des
peuples et j'entends non racisme
anti-jeune je pensais jules vallès j'ai
écrit ce livre pour ceux qui ont
souffert etc j'aurais pu tomber sur les
sûr
sur l'église de scientologie
j'aurais pu tomber sur sur ordre nouveau
j'aurais pu tomber n'importe qui à ce
moment là me voyez avec mon petit sac ma
mère m'avait donné un billet de 50
france pour ma vie j'aurais pu tomber
sur quelqu'un qui m'aurait dit écoute on
peut aider j'y allais j'avais besoin de
ça il tombe sur des gens alors
évidemment le gauchiste mais je sais pas
ce que c'est moi tout ça mais ouf que
mais grâce à vous a repris vos études
alors j'ai repris mes études puis alors
après et s'est arrêté parce qu'il
fallait qu'on arrête les études pour
faire la révolution mais en tout cas
grâce à eux je rentre dans les
bibliothèques et les musées je rentre
dans les musées collègues la musique
jeux qu'est ce que c'est qu'un livre et
c'est à dire que brusquement dans l'aude
je viens d'un monde où il n'ya pas de
cris pas de culture je suis désolé c'est
terrible à dire ça mais je viens d'un
monde de sottise de silence de mensonges
et tout d'un coup ça s'ouvre comme ça on
savoir à la connaissance il vous sortent
de la drogue al oui parce que oui ah oui
tout est dit parfait donc oui c'est à
dire que j'ai un souvenir même qui était
brutale je crois que vous allez trouver
ça bravo je me souviens qu'ils étaient
assez brutal bon je je je prenais un peu
drôle comme tout le monde à l'époque et
des copains mao donc ont débarqué dans
dans la chambre de bonne ils ont tout
pété ce qui est ce qu'ils avaient etc
puis m'ont dit tu arrêtes j'ai arrêté
il y avait une famille alors attendez
pas ce qu'il faut pas quand même joué à
ça il y avait la violence c'est à dire
que la violence de l'ombre de mon père
j'avais encore jeune et je vais me jeu
des mises à la volée recyclés en énergie
créatrice au fond mais en violences
politiques aussi c'est à dire que le
baston
l'antisémitisme le racisme par expliquer
à quelqu'un que quatre antisémite c'est
mal comme un moment donné où ça suffit
moi ce que je voulais c'est que la peur
change de camp et donc vous rendiez coup
pour coup
ce aussi donné que vous n'avez pas donné
votre père vous les deniers à ceux qui
lui ressemblent à celui qui leur semble
absolument j'ai besoin de savoir qui tu
es pour savoir d'où je viens
ecrivez-vous dans des enfants de
vous avez résolu l'énigme paternal
j'imagine que ces chiffres sorj
chalandon ont changé la donne 9 w 56 oui
ça c'est le
[Musique]
café café mon père pendant la guerre je
ne sais pas sur les chiffres de son
casier judiciaire malheureusement ils
meurent avant que je me mette la main
sur quasi judiciaires et aux archives
départementales du nord d'ailleurs je
dois aller les saluer parce que sont
d'aider des gens absolument somptueux
ils m'ont dit bah oui à un casier votre
père un quasi il a été condamné par la
cour de justice de lille et oui un
casier vous pouvez venir le consulter
donc je les consulter et là brusquement
et c'est ça qui est bouleversant c'est
que j'avais deux peur moi la première
peur c'est tombé sur un petit collabos
sur un sur lacombe lucien sur une
petite ordure qui piquait des
chandeliers juifs et qui vous auriez un
crime et non non non je vais pas
rajouter une pourriture à la pourriture
non non c'est à dire que où vient
dénonciateur encore pire que tout enfin
une sorte de deux français que quand
voilà la prison ces trois murs de trop
pour eux et finalement vous découvrez un
père qui ont rapporté 5 uniforme en
quatre ans laura était donc déserteurs
de cinq armées différentes en trompant
la mort avec une facilité déconcertante
c'est peut-être ça le plus fou dans
cette histoire c'est d'avoir traversé la
guerre sans dommage sans égratignure ça
confine au génie alors ça confine au
génie c'est à dire ce qu'est ce qui fait
pour être très précaires ils portent 5e
uniforme et mais pour être plus clair il
est dans l'armée allemande s'appelle le
nsk casser des transports allemand mon
grand père pourquoi je suis enfant de
c'est mon grand père qui me dit
un jour ton père en fait c'était et il
avait choisi le mauvais camp et tué un
enfant de
et si six semaines après il se rend à la
résistance ils lèvent les mains donc
c'est un soldat allemand un français a
bien soldats allemands qui se rend et il
fait merveille c'est à dire qu'ils ont à
masquières tp d'une heure communiste et
il fait merveille chasse les bosque coco
midi et c'est
pourquoi il me raconte pas ça pour quoi
juste ça oui mon fils gt1 sting c'était
un peu compliqué la vie et c'est
pourquoi papa tu me lis pas voilà j'ai
été résistant puis j'ai été collabo
c'est vrai plus dans leur maman de c'est
vrai mais juste raconte moi ça pourquoi
tu t'es avant tout autre chose pourquoi
au moment pourquoi moi quand je quand je
reçois ton dossier quand il est mort il
m'avait raconté la plus sublime histoire
du monde et ces tests est incroyable
parce que il pleurait en la racontant
les défauts que tu sache la vérité enfin
grand comédien comédien fauché la
verrine en gagne un j'étais résistants
mais pas comme on l'entend de nos jours
était dans les mains jeunesse
j'étais dans la vision charlemagne et
suis allé me battre en russie et j'étais
même l'un des derniers défenseurs de
berlin et de bon coeur de est là et là
je me dis ça me rappelle quand même
quand j'ai quitté dien bien phu à pied
mais bon c'est pas grave parce qu'il
pleure et moi je le crois et quand je
lis dossier ces dossiers il m'a raconté
mai 45 il me racontait berlin en ruines
la fureur les bruits il me dit trop
groupe i mortimore dans mes bras mon
copain et des gens toute ta vie raconte
que c'est pour la france que nous sommes
et qu'en janvier son dossier en mai 45
il est en prison et loos les lille c'est
michel simon
il est il avait une peur panique de
l'anonymat au fond alors y avait une
peur panique de l'anonymat m'enfin avec
ce qu'ils avaient dans son dossier mais
j'en fais mon miel vous l'avez tiré à
jamais de l'animal en lui offrant ce
tombeau en fait vous avez vous allez
créer une une trilogie autour de votre
père à cette trilogie plus en plus ccc a
fallu je sais pas comment est ce qu'il
aurait pris mais jean pierre améris a
fait avec profession du père
après un très beau film qui était
assassiné par le cos vide mais bon ça
c'est la vie les camps et quand mon père
est incarné par benoît poelvoorde je ne
peux pas m'empêcher dans la salle de
dire papa si tu savais ça y est tu y es
au cinéma quand le dit pierre michaud on
écrit à l'instar de balzac pour dissiper
l'incroyable erreur de ceux qui ne nous
aimaient pas fait magnifique je ne
connaissais pas au fond d'un sentiment
que vous vous n'écrivez pas pour
réclamer justice pour le préjudice subi
mais pour réparer l'enfant flou et qui
est en chacun de nous au fond cet enfant
qui ne cesse d'espérer d'un amour qu'il
n'y aura jamais et surtout
quel rendez vous manqués
et ce rendez vous manqués me hante c'est
trop tard mes soeurs chalandon est ce
que c'est vraiment un rendez vous manqué
parce qu'au fond j'aimerais conclure là
dessus se perd il vous a toujours menti
mais vous a transmis au moins le sens du
romanesque et le talent de raconter des
histoires de vous aimer ça ça va au delà
de vous à moi
ça aurait été un petit instituteur
laïque
kim aurait appris le sens de la liberté
de la fraternité de la beauté de l'art
la culture
la sensibilité qui m'importe vraiment
mieux je suis je pense que l'un des
rares auteurs je pense dans un salon du
livre je me dis mais tu te rends compte
si tu avais été heureux taureauque un
livre ici
quelle est la conclusion de tout ça j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu avec le malheur
elles ont un effet de très beaux liens
je m'en serais passé
merci saint georges merci beaucoup
[Musique]